A very good reason, I want to share it.
USA Rabies is in the shit right now.
It has been for 30 odd years I've been involved with it.
And I've tried at every level as an administrator
to try and get some sort of semblance.
And I work for a professional organization
and I see professionalism
in a whole different sort of way.
To be a good professional you have to be a very, very good amateur.
What we're doing here tonight is extremely amateur.
A hotbed of USA Rabies was this club, Rabies.
And it was really, really strong in the 70s and 80s. It was awesome.
The tournaments, there would be teams from the UK,
from Australia, from everywhere. They'd want to play the Chicago Lions
or the Belmont Shore
or Nova or Washington Rugby Club.
We don't get those tours anymore because of professionalism.
And it's kind of waning.
So how do we get our clubs strong?
Through recruiting, through staying vigilant.
Being very, very good amateurs
turns you into a professional.
Does that make sense?
And that's all that we have.
We're not going to get any better.
Scott Lawrence is in our coaching group.
The Eagles are improving slowly.
But, you know,
I could have retired from this years ago.
But I'm still kind of going because I've got a lot of experience.
And I like to share it.
And I like to become that really amateur coach
on a Tuesday night
in the middle of wherever we are
with new players,
with the two older players.
And that's really the heartbeat of rugby
and as a tribute.
I'll leave it there.
But I think it's just how important it is
to be a really proud of the club
and your teammates.
And as you go into your fall season,
Jose will challenge me on schoolwork
and things to improve upon
as you guys start picking up
years before you get into it.
That's what's driving me right now.
That's why an old shit like this
drives an hour
out of the Shenandoah Valley
to come into town,
which I fucking love.